Welcome home, master and princess.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to Super Liminal.
This music is making me so relaxed and chill.
I'm actually so sleepy.
This is my technically third stream today.
Welcome to membership, thank you.
Tomodachi Life 2, I know.
I know!
Tomodachi Life 2.
The post, they made a Twitter post and it made me kind of emotional.
Because it was just like, after over 10 years, Tomodachi Life is back!
And I was like, 10 years?
I was looking at my physical copy that I have had since the beginning of Tomodachi Life.
Swamp Ghost, thank you so much for the 10 gift, thank you.
It's been 10 years, snake.
I love Tomodachi Life.
Looking mighty nerdy today.
Having witnessed your power to make it rain lemurs and force game announcements into existence.
Is your Pokemon evolution Oshikami?
Can the ghost become God?
And Dracos, thank you so much for the 20 gift, thank you.
Do I look nerdy?
Well, I have my glasses on this morning because I did not put my contacts in.
Because I knew I was going to go back to sleep.
And then, I kept them on obviously for the direct.
And then, I was like, well they make me smarter.
But I hate glasses on me.
Which would you prefer?
Twin tail?
Normal?
Long hair?
Witch?
Twin, twin, long, long twin.
You look super cute.
Frog?
Wait, sorry, every time I close, or I missed some.
Hot dog, hot dog.
Every time I, it's one of those types of games.
Don't worry, the game is chill.
I think the game is chill, right?
This game is chill, no?
Welcome everyone to one of the most chill games ever created.
Is it really?
Is this game really so chill?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, oh, sorry, I forgot to do that too.
There we go.
A high chance of motion sickness.
At best, you can look around more slowly.
Wait, what?
Like I have a high chance of motion sickness?
It's chill for like 95%.
As long as you don't get frustrated.
I can't tell if people are... I thought maybe it was like...
Especially like this background reminds me of like the parable, Stanley parable.
This game made me kind of barfy.
Really?
I don't get very motion sick from games, so...
As long as they're not like VR games, you know?
Oh, wow.
I guess we'll see if I get sick.
It's been a while since I've been able to catch a stream.
I hope you've been well.
Thank you, Flowerworks.
Welcome back.
Thank you, thank you.
It messes with your perception.
I see.
Well, I guess we'll just have to check it out.
Well, I guess that is a warning then.
An official warning for anybody who does get motion sick.
Be careful.
I'll do my best.
I already turned off the motion blur.
I might have to adjust the sensitivity, but I'll do my best to not make it...
So horrible.
I'll try, I'll try.
This menu music is chill.
I know!
Oh my gosh.
As soon as I was listening to this, I've been kind of listening to it while waiting for it to start.
And it kind of convinced me to buy the soundtrack.
I was like, I kind of want to just...
This is like the kind of music I listen to when I'm like in my hotel room.
Just kind of vibing, like alone in Japan.
And I'll be like...
Today was so busy, I can just relax and listen to my jazz.
It's so nice.
Don't listen to those of weak constitution.
It kind of makes me want to talk like this.
Oh, that might have been my controller.
Oh, I forgot to ask.
Is this a controller game or a mouse game?
I don't... Is this a controller game or...
Mouse, mouse, mouse, both, okay.
I could have sworn we played this one.
No, I've never played this before.
Never ever in my afterlife.
Mouse and keyboard.
Cool.
Shall we start?
No game?
It's giving a warning.
Now I'm scared.
I'm going to go to work.
Byebye!
I love it.
I love this kind of...
I think it's safe.
I get a wife?
Oh no, it's one of those ads.
You wake up in the middle of the night and you're like...
There's like blaring in your room.
That's it.
Lumen Corporation!
Wait, I had to read it first, please.
Wait, I didn't...
I did not read what it said though.
Insert glasses are really versatile.
Copy-paste.
208.
My soul?
That's all I have.
That's all I am, is soul.
Perception is reality.
Grab.
How do I make it small?
Like so?
Oh my god!
Joe, look at the membership!
Show me your kittens!
Thank you for the 10 gift toad!
Wait, can I rotate it?
Oh, there we go.
Wait, can I turn it upside down?
Okay.
I thought these were lemons, I'm not going to lie.
How big can I make this?
Wait.
I can make it huge!
Cool!
Wait, so if I do...
How can I make it even bigger?
Wow!
I see.
I'm escaping this place.
You can't keep me here!
I'm already finding the way out!
What the...
You guys hear that?
Oh, it's just anytime I press.
Checkmate.
Get out of my way!
Somebody's watching us.
I always feel like somebody's watching me!
Terms of service accepted.
Congratulations on falling asleep.
Welcome to Somnascult.
Your progress may be monitored by qualified specialists.
This orientation will adapt you to eyelids, our interactive lucid induction dream state in which you retain full consciousness and control.
Okay.
What do you want me to do?
I don't know how to play this game actually.
Please don't make me.
Okay.
What...
Nice.
Do I make everything really small or really big?
I don't know how to play this game.
Name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Chess or liminal?
Chess.
I can only do sideways.
I'll tell you when it's a hot dog.
Oh, wait.
Oh, sorry Ducky, I missed yours.
I was watching your PS demo VOD while in a taxi and I lost it when you were laughing at Madagascar for 10 minutes.
The driver probably thought I was crazy.
I also learned KBBQ in Korea.
They cook for you.
Oh yeah, I've been to some KBBQ places that they cook for you.
It's always much nicer.
Can I make this bigger?
Oh, the motion sickness.
Thank you!
Lots of people caring about the motion sickness.
Bigger.
Hot dog.
I guess it's big enough.
You.
Oh, see, that's a perfect size, no?
Pick it up while really close and look far away.
Excuse me.
I need you to become teeny tiny.
Wait, hold on.
Like so.
Tiny, teeny tiny enough.
Nope, nevermind.
Not teeny tiny enough.
Like so.
Which place is... It goes like there, right?
Where do they want me to...
I think I... I didn't think I need to play chess at all.
I think I just need to leave.
I understand now.
The puzzle.
Once again, I'm overcomplicating.
I'm overcomplicating.
No objects beyond this point at all times.
I made it really tiny.
Oh, but we need an object.
It'll work eventually.
Yeah.
Can I grab this guy from all...
You think you can fool me?
I'll even make your desk tiny.
Oh, I need it back though, please.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Oh.
I don't care!
Well, I thought it was a regular piece.
Oh my gosh, have you guys ever been to those science museums that have like...
The rooms where they like...
Show your heat...
Like your heat on the walls and...
And like they're all optical illusion things and...
I love those types of museums!
And this is just like that.
Okay.
What do you want me to do about it?
Hope you and your cats are well.
Thank you!
I actually had to take my cat to the vet recently.
Wait, can this go through?
Okay, there we go.
Like there?
Heck yeah.
He's okay.
It was Butaro.
He started throwing up again recently and I was worried about him but...
I get the test results back soon.
But a general look at him, they said he was fine.
He wasn't losing weight or anything, so...
Hold right click to rotate.
Yeah, but it doesn't rotate very well.
So much cheese.
Aston Martin would be so cheesed...
About this part of the game.
Wait, there we go.
Wait, I made it smaller.
You think it's big enough?
No, bigger.
That Nikkei when they made Breddy.
Bigger.
No, no, no.
Big.
No, no.
Bigger, bigger, bigger.
Have you guys seen that new Nikkei girl?
How do I make it bigger?
How do I make it so huge?
Look up with it?
Am I gonna die?
This is how Mint gets to the top shelf with cheese.
Wait, what are all these alarms though?
Or they're not alarms, they're just clocks, but...
Who would have their alarm at 12.05?
That would be craziness.
How do I say your name?
Look at the membership.
Daniel, thank you so much for the 5 gift.
Oh boy, 12.05 AM.
What is that, a balloon?
There was no other place for me to go.
Patient safety is a key note in our corporate priority tetrahedron.
A variable degree of force can and will be authorized to ensure patient safety.
Please return to the orientation pathway.
If I stick my finger...
If Dreamself sticks my finger into the socket...
Will we still be okay?
What do you guys want?
Red soda, green soda, diet soda, random soda, baking soda, mini soda, water soda?
Which one?
I'm making green soda.
Please use the other door.
What other door?
Hey, what's up there?
So if I look up...
Wait.
Oh no, I gotta be close to it, my bad.
Be close.
We'll get it.
That's how we're gonna get up there.
Whatever this...
Why is it getting so small?
Come on.
Close or far.
I made it teeny.
The teeniest, tiniest ever.
How small can I make this soda?
Wait, can I even grab it?
Oh my god, I can.
It's so tiny.
This game has a really nice message attached to it.
Hope you finish it.
You got this, Mito.
Thank you!
Soda for ants.
Okay, we'll do the random soda.
What did we get?
We got...
It's still rolling.
Oh, it's actually just called a random soda.
Why am I so bad at making it bigger?
Getting there.
I don't even know if that's actually anything.
But I wanna try.
You might need another one.
Oh, maybe.
Tiny soda.
Tiny soda is our only hope.
I think I broke the soda.
And the soda.
Why is this one so big?
Oh my god.
Okay, alright.
Am I actually getting anywhere you guys?
Am I really breaking the game right now?
What is this?
That's what you wanted me to do.
Where does that go to though?
You like my idea more?
That was the speaker.
There are...
Actually, I can't tell what is the intended method here.
I can't really tell.
Oh, I see.
Down there.
You like my puzzle solving strats?
Thank you.
Can I just...
Oh,
whoopsie.
I thought I would roll enough momentum.
You know.
Put my hands long.
It's a dream.
If you can think it, you can dream it.
How do I get it in there?
Yeah, it does have a jump button.
Try doing it from the middle glass.
I can't grab it from there.
Pretty blue...
Wait.
My eyes magnify my...wait.
Blue eyes plus glasses plus men plus maid equals taking over the world.
Place it directly?
I was trying to before, but it didn't work.
Please provide a comprehensive rational explanation in your post-procedural survey.
Completed surveys may be eligible for a gift card.
This game...
Reminds me of Ivespy.
No items.
People without items beyond this point will be fine.
I'll be fine.
They will be fine.
I think you...
Missed a really important letter there.
It's like an extremely important letter.
Really, no objects beyond this point at all times.
Then how do I... I did it before.
I see.
Gamers don't look up.
Wait, how do I get it all the way up there though?
Bigger?
Can I even make it any bigger?
Bigger.
Bigger!
Holy cow!
Ok, hold on.
Because I imagine I use it...
You guys... Hold on.
Please don't... Please don't...
Just yell the answers.
You guys, I'm trying to figure it out.
Please.
Thank you.
Yeah, no help unless I ask for it.
No help unless I ask for it.
But what I...
Can I... Can I...
Can I get it like...
What?
Maybe from over here.
I did it!
Put this towards some celebratory treats for when your cat feels better.
Thank you!
See, I didn't need no help.
Oh.
Mysterious.
Oh, not lemons.
Oh, there's so many ways to go.
No, there's not so many ways to go.
Wait, it's all the same.
Oh, oh.
Wait, what?
This one too?
Oh, this one too?
Can I just keep going forever?
Spot the anomalies.
Oh no.
Why is this one crooked?
Okay.
And then this one...
I can't take it.
Can I...
Oh, it kicks me out.
It's time to thonk.
I'm always thonking.
Can I...
Gosh, can I make it big enough to where it covers both?
Oh, so, so, so, so close.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I think I need to get close.
I can't even see it when I move it like that.
Hi!
Hold it close and look up?
Yeah, I tried that.
I think I'm just not good at it sometimes.
Fall over, please?
Maybe if I push it.
Now it doesn't.
Final?
Why is it...
What can we see through here?
Oh cheese.
That.
No cheese.
I was wondering if you are listening to Zutomayo.
If so, what's your favorite song?
I know Zutomayo, but I can't say that I've listened to them very much.
I will check out your favorite.
Cheese.
Do we...
Make it big again?
Do we make our world famous cheese platform?
Push!
Push?
Wedge it?
Wait, in between here?
Is that even possible?
I thought I was going to...
We didn't need to wedge it.
We just needed to break it.
I just needed to destroy everything.
What do you guys think?
I'm stupid?
This company.
They think I'm so dumb?
They're like, she'll never beat all the puzzles.
Break stuff.
Excuse me.
If I... I must cheese you a question.
Can't pick any of this stuff up.
Ok.
Loading!
Are your plushies still available?
I think we had to close it for now.
3 AM?
That's a spooky hour.
Are we still in the dream or...
Sweet F?
It was in Sweet B.
Private.
It was suddenly the start of the Stanley Parable for real.
Anybody here?
Sweet F for freaky.
Wait, how to start it?
Wait, what does it say?
How to start it?
I can't tell.
Is the soda still free?
Sorry to the poor sapoo.
Someone comes into work and they're just like, gosh, I just really want a soda this morning.
Cheese.
Cheese!
Red rum, red rum.
Some doors are best left closed.
I still can't take anything yet.
Should we leave?
We could go that way or we could go this way.
Pull the fire alarm.
Wait, here?
I can do that?
Are there more fire alarms to pull?
I've always wanted to pull one before.
She's a ghost so I'm going to try and contact her on the Ouija board at 3am.
Do not attempt this because it is extremely dangerous.
That was a good job on that puzzle, thank you.
Couldn't have done Cheddar myself.
This game is going to be a breeze for you.
I hate being a big person.
I hate being the bigger person.
Well then obviously we need to go this way.
The numbers on this don't make any sense at all.
This one you can pretty easily tell, I'm not going to lie.
Maybe if you get it from just the middle.
Exactly the middle it looks good.
A little Looney Tunes style.
This room looks trippy too.
Wait, there was another exit door.
Let's go check that out.
Exit temporarily moved.
Ok, so we definitely have to go that way.
Just got Minto Goods today and the mouse pad is very buffed.
Oh, mouse pad.
That's not official.
But thank you.
We are on the movie set.
Exit, exit.
How about if I shaman myself?
Probably won't need a Ouija board.
I think it's fun to talk on the Ouija board though.
It's kind of like texting.
Hey girl, how old are you?
Hey girl, ASL.
Like that, you know?
Wait, what can I interact with?
Because...
Oh no, can I pick up anything?
This?
No.
You?
Something green?
Thank you!
My bad.
Push!
No, no, not me!
No, no, no!
Maybe like... I wish I could tilt it, you know?
I'm trying to make a ramp.
But a big ramp, you know?
See, every time I pick it up it makes it so small.
That works.
Staircon?
Well, better than Sawcon.
Probably.
Neat.
Oh!
Like you're trying to find me?
Or...
Because I don't want to be found.
Oh, what's this?
They're plans.
They're big plans.
New cube design.
Too much?
Materials.
Aluminum plastic.
Symmetrical layout.
Table table.
Cloud insert.
Order more red paint.
Math.
Projection.
Eggshell.
I'm a pirate.
What else is around here?
Blue.
It must have...
I...
I'm...
I'm a genius, I think.
I drew those.
I drew that.
Sawcon these.
Every time you say the Sawcon.
Every time.
You have to bring up these.
Wait, what did I just do?
Oh, I think I...
We had a brief moment of music.
The illusion of choice?
The exit sign has light for dark places.
Thank you.
That's so smart.
And I'm not gonna get everything, you guys.
So it's okay if I miss some stuff.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's not as bright as I thought it would be.
It actually doesn't do anything.
It actually does nothing.
Okay.
People are saying I missed a fire alarm.
It's okay.
Oh, here it is.
Oh,
wait.
It's one of these.
Where you line it up perfectly.
Probably from back here.
Wow!
Cute.
No, very scary.
Perception is reality!
Another one.
Is that a bullet or...
Oh no, it's part of the table.
Oh, there is a lot of them.
Another cube.
Okay, okay.
Please, that's like basically perfect.
That was so perfect.
Hello?
It's basically...Oh, I have to grab it.
It's not a cube at all.
It's not a cube.
Roars and gowls.
Oh, it becomes like a staircase.
There is some slight collision physics.
Bigger?
I like the soundtrack for this game so much.
The exit.
Hmm...
I mean the...Hello?
Hello?
What can I grab here?
Pictures?
Picture?
Now you guys are making me want to pull all these.
I probably missed some already though, no?
You don't have to.
I'll try and get all that I can.
It's the right thing to do.
Can we bring the staircase box?
Good question.
I love your dredge playthroughs.
Oh, thank you!
I'm still working on playing it.
For your inevitable sea shanty karaoke messages, looking up the band Longest Jawns.
Hoist that up the thing.
Seems like a perfect theme song.
I'll look into it, thank you.
Wait, eh?
What am I doing wrong?
There we go.
No, no, no.
Oh gosh.
Okay, okay.
Raiders?
Nyaruto!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
This is my first time playing Super Liminal.
And...oh yeah, what's this?
Is this a hint?
Remac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
RugbyRabbit, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Doharku, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And Draco, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Uh-oh, this is my staircase now.
I messed it up.
Murphy, thanks for the 5 gifted!
GDontcha, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Hold on, I missed one.
CC, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Resume.
We did it!
We're back into the spooky.
Oh, purple.
What's this?
Oh my god.
What is this?
It's just a room of stars?
Secret area?
The edge of the universe?
The meaning of...
What did I just hear?
Is there anything to do here except just stare at the pretty room?
Can I grab a star?
I could really use a wish.
Right now!
Wish right now!
Interesting.
Star bottom right.
You just...
That's your zodiac?
Yeah, me too.
Wait, is it make anything else except a table?
I noticed that there was like a large cluster, so I figured it was something.
You're my bestie, you.
Me!
Yeah, everybody now, if you're just like on, you know, a date and...
Person's like, what's your zodiac sign?
You could be like...
Table.
It's like, you know...
One of the rarest zodiacs to get.
I think there's a cup.
Oh wait, this is like right here.
Looks like it could be something.
Or like...
This like cluster here.
I'm trying to use my third eye.
Oh wait, there's here too.
This also look like a cluster, no?
Yeah, an anime girl told me that's my...
This too!
That's my sign.
So, you know, just...
But you have four eyes.
Who you calling four eyes?
Who you calling?
Pushes on my glasses.
Guys, I think I'm blind.
I can't see anything other than the table.
Do you guys see anything else?
This is harder than finding hidden Mickey's.
That's why you wear glasses.
What's your prescription on your glasses again?
I don't know what my prescription on my glasses is, but my left eye is...
Negative 3.5 for contacts and my right eye is negative 4.
See the most beautiful ghost in the world.
It's only one unsecret room.
At least we found the table.
Cool.
I like that room.
Oh the professor.
Doctor.
We still don't know.
But please keep moving forward and hopefully you prefer frequent updates to being reminded that you are completely lost.
Thank you doctor.
Doctor, doctor.
Rice and shipping box.
Rice cakes and assorted candies.
Candies.
It wasn't here.
I went to the eye doctor this week and they told me I legally shouldn't be driving.
So I'm getting glasses soon.
Astigmatism gang, rise up.
Wait, you did not know that you couldn't see?
How did you not know?
I don't know what I'm doing or how to support but take money.
Custom music, thank you.
I love the rookie numbers.
I'm 7-0 in both eyes, that's insane.
Zkinator, thank you so much for the pink.
If you were the stars I would devote...
Is this a poem?
I'm gonna get embarrassed.
Thank you for the pink.
Four eyes for life.
Yeah, pretty much.
Pretty much, you know.
What can I interact with here?
Yeah, how did you not know that you could not see that badly?
Is my question.
Nice riz.
Okay, I'll read it.
I'll read it.
Oh my gosh.
Fine, I'll read it.
I'm embarrassed though.
If you were the star I would devote my life to being an astronomer.
If only to begin to understand your beauty.
If I were to stare at your eyes forever, I would tell people I saw the entire galaxy without even looking at the sky.
Like staring at our screens all day is bad.
No, my eyes have been this bad.
Ever since I was a wee wisp.
Well, they've gotten worse.
They used to be like 2 point something and now they're 4 point something.
I can see which shapes are cars because they go low.
As the one computer science major that doesn't need glasses, I say skill issue.
I'm old and still have 2018 vision.
Get rekt, nerds.
How old are we talking?
It's not a competition.
I'm not here to be like...
I'm not bragging about my prescription.
Do you guys see anything in here that we can interact with?
I don't see anything.
Well,
that's why I wear contacts, because I don't like my glasses.
Think cube, the green wall.
I thought I needed to be up here for it, though.
I don't think I can get it unless I'm upstairs.
Yeah, I'm not tall enough.
Oh my god, I didn't even see the cube!
I see it now.
Yay!
Oh wait...
Yes, yes, use your arms!
Use your arms.
Wait,
then what about this room?
I like this game.
Okay, before we go through this exit...
Why is there a tiny door?
Maybe it needs to be bigger.
Nevermind.
What about this door?
And our green cube we got all of a sudden.
It's father and son.
Yes.
Yes, papa.
Telling lies?
No, papa.
Open your mouth.
What if I do like this?
What if I can crawl on here?
I think it's really sturdy.
Okay, I'm gonna go... wait.
Oh, I think I messed up.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
I'm gonna go through this one first.
This
area seems... not good.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm getting a cough drop.
Guys, it's bad.
I have a recording tomorrow.
My voice is so bad.
I think I messed up.
Good luck, thank you.
Okay, thank you cube.
I need to see what's in this area for real.
Oh, wow.
Now if I use this chest...
Can I jump up?
No, okay.
Yes!
Just finished 45 minutes straight on my old workout bike.
Nice!
I have a recording tomorrow.
I guess I'll stream three times.
I was... I don't know.
What kind of dice?
Is that a gnome?
What is that?
Sterecon!
More Sterecon.
Oops.
Roll the dice.
Oh, it's apples!
Sterecon...
Three.
Or one.
I don't understand this one.
Holy cow.
I don't get this one.
It's always a one!
It's rigged!
I
don't really get it though.
Thank you!
Is it that?
Since that's like...
Since it's like kind of...
Like it's kind of green.
Like the chess piece.
Makes me think that we could... I don't know.
I think it's just an easter egg.
Maybe.
Okay, let's go.
Hello Minto.
Hello!
Hello.
Why would it be there then though?
That is...
925-ish?
About?
1025?
Watching you stream made it feel like easy breezy.
I haven't done my workout today.
I was too lazy.
Well, not lazy.
I was too tired.
I was definitely too tired and didn't do my workout.
Is that okay?
Is it okay if I didn't do my workout today?
Please say yes.
It's okay?
I won't miss it again.
I don't know about that.
Get back to it tomorrow.
Yes mom.
Wow!
You can really see the moon now.
Trying to find...
Something to use.
Any dice?
Shoot for the moon Minto.
Wait, you think I can grab it?
For example, if you see your parents, please punch them in the face as hard as you can and immediately run away.
Wow you guys, I give you the moon.
Look, look, look.
Now you can really say it.
Say it, say it.
Say the line, say the line.
I didn't do my workout today.
I didn't do any work because I was laid off!
I'm laid off!
The moon is beautiful.
What do you want?
The moon?
Well then how about I lasso it for you?
Good job team, good job team.
Okay so now we have to probably precariously stack these up I imagine.
Wait, come here.
Come here you.
Wait, what's on the other side?
The exit!
Wait, I thought I was having to go up.
But no, I go through.
Can I go up still?
Can I go up?
We are going to need a big old cheese...
ramp for a big block.
Okay, big enough of a cheese ramp I think.
That scared the heck out of me.
It scared the heck out of me.
Oh my gosh.
Big cheese.
Do you think we can make it outside?
If you were the moon, I'd be the tides.
Naturally draw it to you?
What is this?
Oh wait, I think I made it small.
No!
Big old cheese.
Come
on, come on.
Yes, yes, no!
Yes, yes, yes!
No!
Is it a razor clock or something?
I don't know, you tell me.
Use the moon!
I think I need to be far away from the moon.
Just kidding.
Wait, why does it make it so small?
How do I make it bigger?
Because the moon floats, it's kind of hard.
You grab from afar.
That's what I tried doing.
Let me try again.
All the way.
You
pick up close and release...
There we go!
Thank you so much for that!
We made it!
There is something up here!
I think I need the soda can.
I want to get up there again first.
Ok, there we go.
Is it grab the moon again maybe?
Maybe.
We
made it!
Creepy, creepy.
Popcorn!
We made it!
I don't like it with the lights off though, it's freaking me out.
There's clocks here, there's not there.
The sky is fake, it's because of the light.
No!
I turned them all off.
That's so sad.
Bye music.
I know it gets really creepy in these areas.
Is there a...
Whatchamacallit?
A fire alarm that I can pull?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Well we made it!
We made it!
Good job team.
Check the blue...the what?
Blueprint?
Where do you see it?
Blueprint.
On the other side of the room.
This?
Oh I see.
Thank you guys, I totally missed it.
It's a blueprint.
Wow.
What's this door?
Freaky.
Oh we got that, that's neat.
It's so blue, I know.
Let's keep the lights on.
Let's keep the lights on, it's prettier this way, no?
Even if it's fake, even if it's fake.
The blueprints are obviously for Metal Gear.
Alright, that's enough...being silly.
Onwards!
Don't get lost.
Beer fund $5 Dakota.
Regular person 3-5 dreams per night.
Really?
Don't meet sister-in-law.
What if there is a fire in elevator?
Nobody answered that one.
Can I write it?
Seize the day.
Oh I'm a ghost.
Other Somnoscope resorts are waiting for you.
Now Metal Gear...
I think my loading bar is broken.
Oh we woke up again!
Good morning Mito!
We are in the same place.
As before.
Is this one working?
It's not working.
It's not my fault.
Dice.
Warning, dice.
It's not my fault I think.
Probably.
Curators only.
Rating schema.
Perception is real.
The same guy?
No, no, no, no.
Oh there is a dice.
This one is also apples.
Excuse me.
There we go.
You can't contain me.
I almost missed it.
I don't know if this dice is loaded too.
Seems like this place is a whole bunch of phonies.
Bunch of phonies.
Wait just like, this is half a dice.
The other half?
Nice.
Bunch of phonies.
Oh I almost missed it again.
What if it affected the real world and they are like just dealing with never ending like...
The electricity is just completely haywired and...
Everything is bad.
Everything is destroyed.
Oh!
Secret passage.
Dream diary made.
Monday May 2nd.
Started in the bathroom.
Was walking towards the door but couldn't reach it.
Voices on the other side of the door.
They were saying something like a nursery rhyme.
Intense feeling of deja vu.
Tuesday.
Floated through space for what felt like 7 hours.
This sounds nice.
Plenty of stars and no planets in sight.
Wednesday.
Stared...
Wait.
Started on the sofa in my living room.
Couldn't move.
Your sleep paralysis team?
Thursday.
Began with falling off a huge cliff.
Right before landing.
Fell back up to the top of the cliff.
Repeated this many times.
Realized I had...
20...
No.
No hands.
Wandering through a seemingly endless forest.
Wolves howling in the distance.
Oh, that was Friday.
Weekend.
Took the weekend off so as usual, no dreams.
What do you mean no dreams?
Oh yeah, there are two Wednesdays.
You're right.
Monday.
Was eating cereal for breakfast.
Kept eating the cereal but it kept refilling.
Cereal everywhere after a while.
Tuesday.
Arguing with my best friend in high school.
We were in a bank.
I think we were getting a loan or something.
Sounds too real?
Too realistic.
Are we in 1991?
2?
Oh my gosh, it's the How to Start It!
Maybe just use Butler?
But one to appear personable.
Hi, I'm Dr. Pierce and you just started your Somniscope therapy session.
Hey, Glenn here.
Welcome to your first ever Somnisculture.
Welcome to the future.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce and I cannot wait to show you what we've been working on.
Greetings, traveler.
Welcome to the wonderful world of Somniscope.
I am Glenn Pierce and will be your guide on this journey.
Good afternoon and welcome to Somniscope.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce and I'm looking forward to helping you.
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Welcome to Somniscope.
Open your eyes.
Welcome to the future of medical treatment.
My name is Dr. Pierce and I invested... invented Somniscope.
Given time, we can and will solve everything.
What do you think this guy's name is?
Was he... he's getting relaxium gas?
This guy's full of gas.
Facts.
What am I made of?
Money?
Yes, don't tell anyone about this.
Steve.
I am Steve.
Uncle Julio's rice pudding.
Nice.
Plywood sheets.
Anti-vib pads.
What's that?
Fire extinguisher.
That's a hefty bill.
We can move on.
I
think this is just gonna be a loop.
Maybe if I... wait.
Grab clothes.
And place far.
I wish I could place it further.
Okay, well.
We have this.
And this.
What's over here?
My game just saved.
It scares me when it saves.
It scares me.
I don't like it.
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
That's plenty big, no?
You don't want it to save?
I think something bad is gonna happen.
Everyone knows in a horror game when it saves...
Something bad's about to happen.
What is it?
We can just move it.
Come on, peace.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Hearing so many people skip their workout motivated me to do mine.
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you, Wisps.
You're welcome.
Okay, for me though, it was like...
It was like... Not that I didn't want to do it, I just...
I took a nap, okay?
I took a nap.
Oh, I don't think I can bring anything through here.
Nope.
Wait, they looked all messed up through here?
But they're actually messed up.
Relatable.
You thought they were messed up from afar, but in reality...
They're messed up.
They're messed up!
But this one actually got me.
I thought these were real dice.
Oh my gosh, this one actually got me.
I guess
they're really good about fire.
They're very cautious.
What the...
What is this?
Okay.
Can I move the...
This game is a workout of the mind.
Truly.
Oh, there's one over there too.
Is there anything else we can move?
What's the end goal?
Psychos, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
And Geru, welcome to the membership.
It's got a nice sound.
The side of the dice.
What do you mean the side of the dice?
I can't adjust it while I'm on it.
Mitsu blind?
What do you mean?
What do you mean I'm blind?
What am I missing?
How am I blind?
Oh shoot.
It says side of the dice, but I don't know what you mean by that.
I think they want you to grab the gold pawn, but I don't know if you can.
Yeah, you can't grab that.
Or this.
Or...oh there is not one for this one.
Bike sack!
Thank you so much for the...thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, I appreciate it.
She lacks depth perception.
I already know this.
What way haven't you moved the columns?
I don't know.
There is a thingy there.
Wait, maybe I can get it?
No, no, no.
Dang it.
You see it?
Eat the apple.
I don't know!
Can I get a hint?
She lacks critical information.
Clearly!
I don't know.
Can I get a hint?
This one is actually stumping me.
I'm trying to get up there.
I know that I can do this.
But I want to get up there.
You guys!
I said that there was a thing up there I wanted to try and get.
I wonder if I just have to be kind of...precision...you know.
Ah!
Oh no!
I ruined it!
Stack the die.
Maybe like this.
No!
I don't know.
Can you move it while you jump?
No, it doesn't seem like it.
I just didn't do it at the right angle.
Mission accomplished.
Oh!
Is he going to kill me?
Oh god!
He's huge!
I feel like there's got to be something around here with this duck.
There we go.
I'm on him.
I've taken down the duck.
His name is Rick?
Nah.
His name is Ducky.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry!
It's like Eeyore's house.
Sorry.
I heard something...
I just wanted to look over here and now I ruined it.
Oh my god.
No!
I have to do it the silly way.
Or I get all close.
That should be good, right?
There we go.
Nice.
Private.
Someone is going to the bathroom in there.
What happens if I touch this one?
Everything I love to touch dies!
Oopsie.
Emotions slash expectations.
Highly affect dreams.
You are here.
Jonas Dawson, Arthur Willis, Jojo Smith.
Dream layers of the mind.
People only dream of ordinary objects.
Boring!
There is this one.
Oh what happened to Bart?
Let's do casino.
Jojo!
How long is this game anyway?
It's 5am.
30 hours.
Few hours.
A little hours.
Some hours.
Oh they are brown now.
Waterfall, right?
Oh, we don't get an answer.
I'm going to say yes.
Please tell me doctor.
What's wrong with my broke brain?
Doctor.
Doctor help me.
Guys, what if I were the doctor?
The doctor is in.
There are so many...
Oh I don't like that.
Are you guys sure this isn't a horror game?
See?
Red means scary!
Are you guys sure?
Are you guys sure this isn't a horror game?
What's shining here?
Oh they are like windows.
Oh I see, I see.
Emergency generator this way.
You are a ghost?
What are you scared of?
Ghosts in video games are spooky!
Suddenly a zombie apocalypse.
No it was the exit!
What if I go back?
It's nothing.
This game is spooky.
Way spookier than I thought.
Let's see if I'm able to interact with anything.
Oh my gosh!
Run girl!
Thank you for the hug!
Wait, did you cause this?
Guys, there is a handprint.
There are handprints!
Big.
I'm just going to keep going?
No!
What's today?
No it's Thursday!
No!
I'm scared.
Thank you for the five minutes.
Thank you.
I'm scared.
Thank you for the gift.
I should have saved this for Sunday.
So true.
Perception is reality, but I don't know what to perceive.
Go into the dark?
No!
Ghost is like an encompassing term like dog.
Mint is a Pomeranian.
Other ghosts are like German Shepard.
No, I'm really scary though.
I promise.
Am I doing it?
The lights in this room suck.
I think they really need to...oh my gosh.
Just die!
Die!
Guys, don't freak out.
It's just diet soda.
What were you freaking out for?
Murder, murder, murder is still on the menu.
Who are we murdering boys?
How far does this go?
I'm at the edge.
Why is this part so scary?
Super liminal.
I did not sign up for this.
Diet soda.
What does it mean?
Ok, not that way.
I see.
Did I go this way?
Thank you murderer!
Thank you murderer for lighting up the...thank you.
He just wants to see my scared face even more.
What do you have to say now?
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
And I'd like to talk more about the feelings of worthlessness and self-doubt I mentioned before.
You feel this way because you want the kind of happy life you see all around you.
The kind you know everyone else is enjoying.
And that's exactly why we're here to help.
I think if I went to this place and I had a dream about...
Something's going to pop up here.
Nevermind.
If I had a dream about maybe potentially getting murdered.
I think I might sue the place.
It's a chess piece.
I was going to say, that's a really short person.
That's a teeny tiny guy right there.
It's just paint, right guys?
Don't turn around!
Wait, this way?
Wait, where?
This way.
Thank you!
Which way?
That looks pretty bad.
Wall into darkness.
Wait, I missed a stair?
There's a stair?
This way?
I see, I see.
Alright.
This is not me!
I am new to your community.
I've seen some clips here and there.
I want to enjoy it more.
I watch your streams.
I can't wait to see Spoopy and my toys.
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Welcome, you give me strength.
I'm not scared.
I'm just a little scared.
Wait, I'm scared!
I lied.
I'm very much scared.
I'm scared.
How do I get... do we go up?
Is there anywhere up?
How do I get out of here?
What if I go back?
Nothing, it seems.
I almost missed it.
Yeah, get Woolooloo'd!
Oh
wait, hold on.
My bad, my bad.
Grab close.
And make big.
Big.
Make big.
Guys?
It returned!
Oh my gosh, they thought of everything.
What am I supposed to do here with the light?
I didn't see anything that seemed like... you know.
Wow, that really lights up the room.
Nice.
OK, now we can see.
But I can't see what to do.
Is
that the right idea?
I didn't know what I was doing though.
Fit.
No?
This room?
You can't remove the planks.
Oh my god!
Can I take you back please?
Please ma'am.
Let me take you back.
I made a mistake, please.
We are in the Ryan Shipping... what is this?
Ry-san, my bad.
I can't see anything, but we are just going for it.
If I can't see anything, nothing is scary.
Maybe.
We made it!
Only one?
So cheap.
Emergency generator this way.
OK.
I'll follow you.
We are not out yet.
No, please.
It's too spooky.
It's so spooky.
Good job, Minto.
Thanks.
Oh, I thought that went through for a second.
We definitely need to find... maybe it lights up.
Like that.
Diet soda, diet soda, diet soda.
Gosh, I really like diet soda.
Oh no.
There we go.
Make it real big.
Make her big.
Ready!
Holy cow!
Guys, we are in the actual tanning bed right now.
Oh I see it!
I see it!
I found it.
99% of patients who are able to follow simple instructions from the standard orientation protocol.
The murderer was right there!
Where did the knife go?
The murderer took it, obviously.
Oh golly, oh golly, oh golly, oh golly...
Ikea?
Idea!
Everything is fixed.
Oh we have the regular music back!
It was the red paint!
And stacks of it.
I need to go out that window.
Opposite your name right?
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We made it, you guys.
We made it.
Why did he drag the paint all through here?
What a silly goose that guy is.
Ugh.
The jokes are real.
Can I go up here?
Fascinating.
Is there anything I can interact with in here?
Oh I guess all the windows are open, nevermind.
I thought only that one was.
Here we go!
Eggshell.
Oh that's the color!
There's a blueprint in the kitchen?
Oh thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Can we softlock ourselves?
Oh!
The beans!
Wait, I don't see it though.
Oops.
No.
OK, we got it.
I don't see the blueprint.
It's Sunday already?
Gosh, these days just get shorter and shorter.
And then what about the other days?
Backer room.
Blueprint, blueprint, blueprint, blueprint.
Looking for mega blue.
Looking for the bluest...
Oh wait, I think if I use the beans we can hop over this, no?
Not the beans!
Come here bean.
It's not Sunday.
What is it?
Dream architect.
Anything else in here?
Wait a second.
Wait.
Oh wait.
Are there any more beans?
Gosh.
Dama!
Thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you!
Hello, hello.
Where did I put my beans here?
Oh, I can't grab them.
Guys?
No way.
Why are you going to let me grab them?
Guys, I think I've...
I think...
I think we've beaten ourselves.
No!
Remaking to the gifted!
Jump on the dolly?
This one over here?
Who said that?
Who said jump on the dolly?
Gaspar!
You saved the stream.
Is there anything on this side?
I won't make the same mistake again.
Doesn't seem like it.
How
much is in these beans?
Serving size 5 wads.
1200 calories per serving?
How much is a wad?
Like a big old...
Like that?
Like you just scoop it up and...you know?
I might be making a mistake, but...
This is how adventures happen.
Eat one and you're done.
Yeah, you're basically done for the whole day.
Ok, can I...
do this?
Oh I made it, but it's nothing!
No!
No adventures for us you guys.
No adventures for us.
Second breakfast.
Oh the cloud insert.
That's probably what we were looking at.
Banana yellow.
Order more red paint.
Yeah, because someone wasted it all.
Good job team.
Other window.
Avocado?
Need to sleep.
Promotes heart health, anti-cancer, blood sugar regulation, potassium, anti-inflammatory.
Why?
Too many?
How many really?
I hate avocado.
Self-doubt worthlessness.
I don't like avocado.
You do?
Yeah, I don't like it.
Even as a guacamole, I don't eat guacamole because I don't like avocado.
Maybe send me a good avocado recipe and I'll try it.
What?
You're literally green?
Oh do you like everything your color too?
What are you... What Raymak?
What?
You also grow or shrink based on perspective.
Apparently in fan art.
Flesh colored?
You love everything flesh colored?
Avocado is like a bland potato.
I just don't like it.
I'll eat it if I... Oh I thought it said evil.
Uh-oh.
They're really trying to get us up, huh?
We're on an adventure.
Nick, tell me if you guys send me... Oh gosh, I thought that was a face for a second.
If you guys can send me a good avocado recipe on Twitter, I'll make it.
I'll try it for real.
No message?
I like the music in this game.
A lot.
Oh we're back to basics!
Oh.
Well that's just... a stinkin' shame.
Why
would they do this?
Anything out here?
This bucket?
No.
Here?
Gamers, don't look up.
The door, but I would have to... Oh, this one.
Sorry, I thought I used it all the way over there.
They're both even green!
Just like me and avocados.
10 months of best ghost.
Thank you!
Sidewinder0, thank you.
Oi!
Wait, I gotta time it.
I'm just a little bit off.
This one sounds like your theme song.
Which one did you want?
What are we feeling?
How many are there?
It's a very smooth jazz.
A very smooth jazz.
Lo-fi.
One issue with too many lo-fi tracks is that the percussion always hits too hard.
What do you guys think?
Does it hit too hard for you?
It's just how it is.
It's such a lo-fi thing.
It's the only thing that makes me not able to vibe so much with it.
Because I'm always just hearing the click.
First one with the saxophone was good.
I agree.
Wait, where's the saxophone?
Two?
Ah, this one.
This sounds like a Pokemon city.
Oh, it just keeps...
Collision physics.
Wait, can I turn on my auto clicker real quick?
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Auto... wait, hold on.
Auto...
Wait, click...
No!
I didn't download it again on my new computer!
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna download it.
Was it on this... where did I get it from?
Hold on.
Maybe it was this one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Install?
Okay, hold on.
Yeah, I got a new computer a little while ago.
Okay, auto... wait, no, no, no.
Auto... auto... clicker.
Wait, click...
Why isn't it loading?
Hello?
Installed.
Oh, I got it.
One millisecond and then we'll do hotkey.
Oh no, we can just do this one.
You guys ready?
It's not as many as I thought it would be.
There's a limit?
No, there's not.
Come on game, let me play.
Let me play the game.
It literally won't let me do it anymore.
Come on game.
Don't... there's not even that many.
Oh, what do we do here now?
Okay, so this is a puzzle.
Here I thought we were just having a good time.
I did see, though, over here.
This is just like yesterday's Lemurs.
Stairway to heaven, baby.
Baby?
Oh.
This requires you to note the following risks of dream overexposure.
Significant memory loss, both quantitative and qualitative.
Hallucinations of dreaded or annoying objects.
Unrealistic beliefs about the lengths of hallways.
And other side effects which have not yet been discovered or which cannot be understood.
Okay.
I'm sorry, I was getting rid of my auto clicker because it remained on the screen.
Resume.
Okay.
Right click to return.
Okay, but also shut up, please.
No, please shut up.
No, god, please.
No, please!
Oh, thank goodness.
I was just going to keep making more until it stopped.
Let me out!
This hell.
Oh, I thought they were eyeballs for a second.
It's morning already.
Perception is reality.
You think if you stared at this for long enough and then you blink your eyes, you see baby Jesus?
Oh, purple.
No!
Right click to return.
What if I just push it?
She didn't notice it.
Notice what?
What didn't I notice?
No, full grown Jesus.
My crosshair changed.
Where?
Wait, what if we just fill the room with apples?
So
many apples!
Oh god, you guys.
You guys, there are too many apples!
There are too many apples!
It won't let me make anymore apples.
I opened it?
No I didn't.
I
knocked the sign over.
But if I keep making more I'm just pushing it off so it's actually kind of working.
Push!
Yeah!
I did it.
What's two?
Wow.
Oh, sorry.
Big ol' fan.
Boy is this going to blow me.
Wow, didn't even blow me away even a little bit.
Nothing can impress me I've seen it all.
Huge fan by the way.
What about these papers?
Wouldn't it be so bad if the fan breached them and made a huge mess for whoever has to clean that up.
I wish you luck, Minto, on this area.
Wait, why?
I'm scared now.
Fake fan!
Could be.
Wait, who changed the music?
Who changed the music?
My last strat worked so why wouldn't this one?
What is crashing over there?
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
Ok, hold on.
No, no, no!
Oh no!
Please giant apple!
Please!
You can do it!
Once I push this though...
Oh, it's going to send it shooting everywhere.
Why are you rolling on your own?
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
I'm pushing it with the apples.
So we're going to basically spam it through the fan with the apples.
You understand?
Oh, let me make anymore.
Oh, now they're... You guys, they turned into peaches.
I don't know what's happening.
Why are they pink?
Nah, you can't pick it up.
Do I have to block this and then fill the room with apples?
Great job recreating the Sisyphus tree.
Why is this one so spinny?
It has it's own little mind.
Come on, get in there.
Get in there.
Oh!
Why are my apples radioactive?
Radioactive, radioactive.
Falling in is okay.
Okay, let's see where it leads then.
Oh, okay.
But my apples don't return.
Is there one up here maybe?
I think.
What if I... I was going to say what if I pick up enough of these, but you can't pick up anything.
Can I just turn you off?
I know how to turn you off.
Hi, I'm Mimphanto.
Welcome to my stream.
Hello.
Today I'm going to be doing food ASMR.
Where I'm going to munch and cringe really loudly.
Radioactive.
I pressed right click.
No!
My giant apple!
I'd say a nice try, but bad try.
How did I make the big apple?
New York!
Everything
is perspective.
Wait a second.
Hello.
Huh?
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Oh, this is still happening.
I was going to ask.
If you guys don't mind, if you know this game.
If you don't mind giving a little bit of a warning before we get into like...
I know some people said there's like a lot of motion sickness stuff.
I don't know if that's like a certain part of the game.
So if people don't...
If people could give a warning in the chat like...
Hey, we're about to enter the sicky zone.
Doc feels good now.
After a few discreet eliminations, I would like to resend my statement from before.
You are now the best mate.
What do you mean?
Gallery?
I don't like this new addition about this.
I want to still be able to pick stuff up.
Thinking with portals.
I mean perspective.
Perspective.
Anything else in here?
You like the glasses?
We're about to enter the motion sickness zone.
Oh, we saw this one before.
With the pirate.
Oh, there's Tiny.
I can make teeny tiny vending machines.
Or big giant vending machines.
It's not even soda.
Oh, Tiny.
Tiniest vending machine.
Oh, now I can pick them up?
Okay.
Sure.
Whatever.
Fine.
Maybe this one will give us...
Give us soda.
Unlimited.
Unlimited soda.
It's so big.
Come on.
I'm hacking the system.
I never have enough soda.
I can't even have soda.
I'm doing this for you guys.
I'm basically an employee at this point.
You could say I'm like a stress tester, you know?
I'm a beta tester.
I'm a beater.
Hello.
Name is my peer, Dr. Glenn.
To the Somnosculpt welcome experience, team of your care leader, patient years 10 development.
Conditions struggle you whatever with?
Professional invention.
Edge science with cutting, a tomorrow can bright.
And buts, no ifs, or look good.
Thank you.
I think things are a little screwy.
What if I forget to set the alarm?
Emergency exit protocol.
Let's just kill yourself.
Oh wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
Dang it.
Door next to the vending machine.
Wait, what door?
There was?
Beater.
Thank you.
I missed it entirely.
Wow, it's purple in this one.
Alright, let's figure out what this bad boy is.
Thank you.
It's a...
It's a vending machine!
They fall.
The stars fall on us.
You ever just think about how we're just a tiny little speck in this whole universe?
How we're just stuck on this floating rock in space.
And how there's so many other floating rocks in space.
And how everything just feels so insignificant.
When you really just put it into perspective of how large space is.
And how much is going on in the universe.
And just that one little problem you have.
It's just like a little... not even an ant.
It's tinier than an ant.
In this whole microcosm of space.
Outer Wilds theme.
Wow, wow, wow.
Nerd.
I thought that was a fruit parfait for a second.
Loading!
Good morning, intel three exclamation points.
7 AM.
The relaxation room.
I hear someone talking.
Wait, these are the blueprints I found.
Years ago.
Do you guys feel relaxed?
Wish they restocked the popcorn though.
LOL
Nerd chill.
About us.
Hello, I'm Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Our mission.
Is perception truly reality?
That's the question we... you... are trying to answer.
Sorry.
Our DICE exhibit will astound and may... and maze you.
It will amaze us.
Beyond your brain's cognitive limit, thus opening your mind up to the new possibilities found within this dimension.
What does all this really mean?
We don't know, but that's okay.
We're working on it.
This is where the music is coming from.
Why does it do that?
Doctor?
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
This is a notification that you have reappeared on our monitoring system after a prolonged absence.
We're back!
Please continue to do whatever you did most recently.
And discontinue whatever you were doing immediately prior to that.
Years ago,
I had a dream.
Dream, dream, dream, dream.
Years ago.
Thank you for all your hard work, you're doing great.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you for the superchat.
And we're back, baby.
Even that's back, baby.
And our drink machine is back, baby.
Two diet sodas.
Lucky.
Uh...
Everybody?
I have an announcement to make.
I drank the last of the milk.
And I did not replace it.
Why do we feel smaller?
Wait, we are smaller.
Why are we so much smaller?
What?
Wait.
I've become...I'm a baby now.
I've returned to my childhood.
I can't meet the height.
Will you guys think I'm literally the smallest creature in existence?
It's not true.
Oh, this one didn't even give us so many sodas.
Surely this isn't one of those shrinking hallways though, right?
Wait.
Was that a different...
Here it is.
What's in this area?
Hold on.
This might have like a blueprint around here somewhere, maybe.
On the back or on the sides or on the...
The other sides?
No?
Okay.
Shrink the house?
Why?
Oh, is it because it's too big?
Oh wait, I need to make it smaller.
Gotta make it the right size.
Or I need to make it bigger.
Like that.
So...
Thank you so much for the gift, dude.
This should be good, right?
I'm just a... I'm a huge actually.
This game is so fun.
We're back in the back rooms.
Doctor!
Doctor, I'm not supposed to be here!
I'm not supposed to be here!
Is he getting the music with us?
We're back to spooky.
Person turned off by perception inhibitor.
We saw this one before too.
It's a little unsettling, but you know...
Oh, that seems kind of really dangerous.
Nothing?
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
P
.T.?
P.T.?
Actual P.T.
moment?
Back to calm.
Follow the cable back?
Let's try it.
Something on the TV now?
Oh, no.
This is where I was.
Just kidding.
Nothing changed.
I got one guide.
The only me is me.
Are you sure the only you is you?
Oh, plug it in.
Can I actually do that?
I can't.
It does not allow...
Maybe this guy is ruining the vibe.
Nope, okay.
We continue.
This looks like a fancy hotel.
It's Jenga!
Oh!
Okay, that's enough!
Thank you.
Big fan by the way.
No kidding.
It's wet.
Do I
need to make it bigger?
Can I move this?
I cannot.
Window?
Which window?
Window.
Minky.
That's my name, don't wear it out.
I like how you can see the brick wall on each side.
Any window.
What's happening?
Where am I?
Guys, where am I?
What just happened?
Can I open it up?
How do I get inside though?
Let me in!
Oh we are tiny now.
Oh no, I made us too tiny!
Nevermind!
I made us the perfect height.
What happened?
Why did I hit that suitcase?
First school.
The locker room.
I sure hope there is no one in the showers.
This needs a little scrub-a-dub.
I sure hope not.
Look up?
Don't focus on negativity.
It won't spare you from the cage of death, the pain of disease, the cruelty of time, the cold shell of human nature, or the eventual loss of everything you've ever held dear.
Whatever you do, don't focus on that.
Good advice, man.
Thanks, Dr. Glenn.
Thank you, Dr. Glenn.
Thank you.
I think I messed that up a little bit.
There we go.
Why are they becoming such liminal spaces now?
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do the world's biggest cannonball!
Then literally everyone dies.
Danger.
High voltage.
This machine is remotely controlled and may start without warning.
Don't like that.
I'm venting.
Oops.
Oh shoot.
I actually don't know where it went.
Hold on.
Where do we need to land it?
Oh, up there I think.
Okay, okay, okay.
I see what we need to do.
What if I just made it the largest thing ever though?
We could get there ourselves.
Guys, I think I messed up.
Guys, I think I made it too big!
I made it too big!
You guys, I'm stuck inside the...I'm stuck in the floaty.
Just kidding.
Let me in!
Oh I'm so slow.
You guys, I'm so slow.
Guys, I'm crawling out of worm space.
Oh god, things are starting to glitch out.
Oh no!
I'm so small I have to jump over every individual vent.
I'm so tiny.
Oh my gosh, I'm literally pocket sized.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm so slow.
How did I make it so big?
Oh, can I make it up?
Wait, I don't think I can see above the thing.
Oh please.
No please!
I'm too small to do the puzzle.
No, I have to go back.
No please!
10cm Minky!
No!
I'm bigger than that.
Oh it's really distorting right here, isn't it?
OK.
Alright, we'll get it this time.
I'm so small I can probably go into the outlet.
OK.
Feels good, right guys?
Why am I so slow still?
I think the room is just big maybe.
Wait, where is the door?
Please.
OK.
Alright.
OK, let's try this again.
No?
Oh, not there.
Down here.
Thank you.
I'm so slow.
Can I get up still?
OK, there we go.
Oh shoot.
OK, just a bit bigger.
OK, in we go.
Alright!
OK guys, now I know what to do.
Just like that.
I'm still really small.
Can I get bigger please?
Sorry, I just wanted to make a biblically accurate size video.
Thanks Bald.
Thanks, I paused the game for that.
No seriously, thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you!
Hello sir!
I'm a beater.
Like real?
I've been told that so many times.
Dr. Glenn Pierce please.
You can't be lying to me anymore.
Biblically big brain...I can't speak.
Wait,
what leads to where?
Dr. Glenn Pippi.
That's not his name.
Does this exit into this?
Sure does.
And then this exits into this.
So one makes me big and one makes me small.
Oh wait, no it doesn't.
Now I'm extra small.
Oh shoot, I need to get extra big.
OK, hold on.
We need to get bigger.
OK, like so.
And then make this a bit bigger.
OK.
Bigger.
Wait, but then how do I fit through?
OK, we got this.
We got this guys.
We got this.
One second.
We are actually thinking with portals right now.
So close!
Please!
Do you think maybe...
I can jump in there.
I cannot.
I'm too big.
No I'm not.
I know how to crouch.
OK, I became a little smaller.
I became a little smaller.
That should be good.
No?
OK, nice.
Oh shoot.
OK, hold on.
Oh no!
I'm not so big.
Wait, why can't I walk on this now?
There we go.
Oh please!
Please!
I need to be even smaller!
Smaller!
Maybe like this.
I'm too thick!
I can't help this ass man.
I've tried everything to get rid of it.
The ass is here to stay I think.
Please.
Please!
OK, I think we are small enough.
Now we just need to...
Get in.
We just need to...
We just need to make it...
Up.
Right?
OK.
Easy!
Oh my god, Andy's room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She did it the wrong way?
Wait, what?
You could have just put the door in the keyhole.
Oh.
My bad.
Oh no.
OK, well we are really slow too so it's going to take us as long as...
No!
Please, come here.
No, like bigger.
Here.
It worked.
It did technically work.
Oh my gosh.
These are excruciating.
They are so slow.
Please, can I walk any faster than this?
I'm trying to walk through...
Sneak through this keyhole but my ass is too big.
That's totally how it goes.
Bring it closer.
I think it landed on me.
Wait, excuse me.
Excuse me, you can...oh wait.
No, I made it too big.
Oh no.
Sorry, I'm getting hungry.
So I was eating a snack.
Wait, I think I need to make it smaller.
Like that.
There we go.
But just also a little bit smaller.
5 to 6 dreams is the absolute limit.
How many are we on?
What am I eating?
I'm eating some goldfish.
I'll have dinner after.
Meeting for Cardboard Lovers Association.
Yeah!
I'm eating goldfish.
You guys know goldfish crackers?
These are the best ones.
Hello?
Oh, we started immediately.
Wait, no!
No!
No, no, no!
Not yet!
Okay.
Hi Minto.
Hello!
Detour.
Detour, eh?
Go tour.
Coffee.
Wait, bad ending?
Really?
Uh oh.
Wait, are there multiple endings in this game?
I imagine this is the type of game that has that.
If only...oh, the paint!
This is real paint.
Okay.
Then what are you going to do about it?
Lady?
I'm a loose screw.
Reformulating?
I want to go in here.
Danger.
I'm not anyone.
I'm not like other girls.
You can't place me in a box and not expect me to break out.
I'm wild and crazy and unpredictable.
They're telling me to wake up I think.
Yeah, nobody puts Minto in the corner.
Wait, it's 3AM again.
Mmhm.
Mao Mao, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Bye bye!
Uh oh.
I bet I could put you in a box if Snake was also in it.
Completely different situation.
We need to break out!
That was wild!
Oh my god!
We got big ol' cucumbers and carrots.
Diet soda.
If I just keep running...
I think this does not count as kidnapping.
Does this not count as like a...
I think this is like a...
Oh boy, 3AM.
Is my vision going black?
Sweet A!
Knock, knock, knock!
Sweet G!
A!
G!
Sweet G!
Sweet B!
Oh my little sweet B!
Motion sickness?
Is this the motion sickness part?
I'm actually not sure where to go.
The music is kind of crazy though.
It will be fine for you, probably.
Mickey's big ass adventure.
Wake up!
What was that?
What was the thing from Stranger Things?
I got it!
Minto, wake up!
I don't like this!
There we go, we got it.
Just a little bit bigger.
Doctor!
My name is Doctor Glenn Pierce.
Thank you for completing the Somnuscult Standard Orientation Protocol.
Before you begin the first phase of therapy, I'd like to briefly describe the finite and fragile nature of the dream state.
Amelia, welcome to membership!
Waking a ghost ma...
Wait, waking up a ghost maid at 3AM?
Gone wrong.
If I can't be happy, I'll never let them be happy.
I'm going to pull every single alarm in here.
We're looping?
We do be looping.
Nevermind, just kidding.
We do not be looping.
OK
Going forward into the darkness.
It's spooky.
Am I actually walking?
No.
Where do I need to go?
Maybe back through here?
OK, OK, OK.
Give me my soda.
Nice.
It's so disorienting.
I can't really tell which direction I'm...
I need to go up though.
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
Do I go up or do I go through here?
Well, I made my decision just now.
I don't think I can make it.
I don't think I can go back.
No, my bad.
Up is an easter egg.
OK, OK.
Anything else I can grab?
No?
We go through.
Hello Doctor.
Anything over here?
I thought I just fell down into the void.
Doesn't seem like it, OK.
Doctor?
Doctor, I don't think this is part of the...I thought these were feet.
I thought they were feet sticking out.
Motion sickness warning for the next few segments.
Thank you.
Oh, we got our block.
Come on.
We are back to normal.
All the way up there?
OK.
Oh!
Why
is the music all serious?
What's happening?
Sorry for breaking your stuff.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Can I get back up there?
I feel like we probably could.
I really tried.
No?
No!
The floor!
Oh, shoot.
I feel like we could.
It's like pretty high up though, isn't it?
Is that another easter egg?
If I were to have made it to the top...
Oh, wait.
Guys, I can't see anything.
OK, we're fine.
No.
I'm just going to go in here.
Just be tall.
True.
Perception is not reality.
What's that sound?
What was that?
P.T.
Oh no, it's this puzzle.
What...
do I need to perceive?
What do I need to perceive?
I'm tempted to backseat?
No, no, no.
Only if I ask for a hint.
Oh, Ding is correct.
Oh no.
What did I do wrong?
Wait, did I do something wrong?
Why are you guys staying?
Wait, what do you mean it's over?
Wait,
I think I might get it.
No!
Gold share!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifts!
Thank you!
Did I just mess it up?
OK, so do I... If it's pointing...
So basically my thought process was, if it's pointing towards these, I have to read them.
Or I have to look at this, or go down this way.
And then...
Then go.
But if it's only pointed towards the exit, I just go.
Wait, so like I look, and then I go?
So since I...
You almost got it.
Figured it out.
Digita, thank you so much for the super chat.
Maybe...Hold on.
Is it like this?
Underway, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
I might need another pair of glasses for this one.
You're so close!
I am!
I was doing so well before, when I wasn't even trying.
It's like the same now, so...
Oh, it's not the same anymore.
I don't understand!
No,
I don't think you can click on anything.
Can I get a small hint, but try not to be like so...
Try to be like really, you know, don't be so obvious.
Muffin!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Where you look matters, okay.
That's what I thought.
But I just don't know when to look and where not to look.
Perception is not reality.
My brain hurts!
Think about the order.
The door sign is always right, but I did it!
What do you mean you can't?
I can't look at it every time?
I'm just not gonna...
No, see?
I don't get it.
I'm looking and I'm doing... I don't know!
Thank you so much for the pink house.
Thank you.
Don't look in the direction of the door sign.
So like this.
I
had it, but I was just looking in the wrong direction.
Oh my... I had it, but I got it opposite.
That's it.
Backwards is not necessary.
It's okay.
I feel better doing it.
Wait.
I had it.
I was right.
I just was doing it...
So I was saying you should look the way of the sign.
And then turn... And then walk backwards.
Whatever.
It's fine.
That word confuses me.
We made it through.
You know what that reminds me of?
Are those... Oh my gosh.
Have you ever had like those...
The... Those like stinking word games that's like...
I hate those things.
Where it's like...
I'm going to a party and I'm gonna bring...
Blah blah blah.
What are you gonna bring?
And you're like... I don't know.
And they're like...
My dice just disappeared.
They're like, no, no.
You'll get it.
You'll understand the word...
The word thing.
I hate those.
I hate those because I never understand them.
Smile.
Road closed.
Word logic puzzles.
Yeah!
They drive me crazy.
They're like, you'll get it.
They never explain the puzzle but they'll be like, you'll get it.
You'll get it.
If you cleared it, the first direction you look is the dead end.
So you always need to look at the wrong way first.
Wait, since I'm... Wait.
The first direction you look is the dead end.
Oh, I get it.
That's why.
Thank you.
Yeah, you gotta make the exit.
Even with the help of triggering mechanisms.
I understand.
What did you say?
Guys, I messed up.
Wait.
I messed up.
Do I just have to make it again with my brain?
Back it up.
Oh, it's gone.
No.
There's so much diet soda.
Thank god the vending machines have other options.
Am I overthinking it?
I am.
In what way?
This game constantly changes the rules on you.
Well, it changes the rules at the very end of the game.
I'm assuming this is the end of the game.
It's right there.
Haunts?
What?
A horse?
What are you talking about?
Horse?
Other side of the room?
Was there something there?
Maybe I am blind.
Thank you guys.
Oh my goodness.
I really was overthinking that.
Be careful.
Alright, go.
Could I have landed over there?
I wonder.
I need thicker glasses.
I'm also just kind of exhausted.
What is that?
A rock.
Not the rock.
It's been a long day.
Where are we?
Oh no, it's this again.
Wait, but I can do it properly this time?
Maybe?
It's a nice bed.
Nevermind.
Wait.
Wow, gothic.
OK.
Normal door.
Oh my god.
Wait, we are back here.
Wake up!
Perception is a reality.
Wait, but there was another door.
I'm zooming.
It's like, hey buddy, you are going the wrong way.
OK.
Forward.
Right.
Straight.
We are zooming.
Please listen carefully for the sound of an alarm clock, which will automatically play if you are approaching a destabilizing dreamweight.
Is that good?
What's over here?
Mysterious light source?
How funny.
Yeah, that part was easy.
It was once I found the arrow.
The mysterious light source!
Was that an elevator?
Staircon!
Where is my car?
Oh my god, it's a wall.
Look at it bending.
Oh this one too!
I'm just going to follow the wall.
Truman Show.
Honestly, a Truman Show moment.
Let's hug the wall here.
Let's hug the wall.
These don't line up.
It looks horrible.
It's our bedroom.
Just making sure there is nothing around here.
Click.
This is so Outer Wilds.
Wait, it's a normal loading!
Hello?
Exciting?
Excitable?
Interesting?
What do fries do when they haven't met in a while?
They catch up!
That was cringe, I liked it.
Hello?
Did you guys hear that?
There is a party going on behind here.
I don't like the... what's it called?
The little effect on the sides.
I don't like that.
There is another dance.
There is other music.
I'm trying to figure out what I can interact with.
What I can do.
L Oh wait, here!
What the?
I think I maybe figured it out.
Woah!
It's fine.
Oh wait, I made it too small.
Is that big enough?
So close.
Ok, hold on.
If you're going to say goodnight, goodnight, goodnight.
Thanks for hanging out.
No!
Is this big enough?
Yeah.
Let's go baby.
Wait a second.
Hold your horses.
Now...
But then if I go in here...
Oh, it's open now.
Forever?
Another graduation.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Yeah, I saw the waiting room too, but I did not know what it was.
Yeah, don't get too small.
I know, I'm going back through, I'm going back through.
We're going to get to normal height.
Ok.
Alright.
Do I need to like, see myself?
But that's impossible.
There is no way.
You could.
There is no way to.
I'm trying to make it big.
No!
Stop please!
Why can't I make it go so far back in the room?
Diagnostic warning.
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented.
Do I just keep breaking it?
I see some people bringing up the rules.
I appreciate it.
You know, obviously...
Try to follow rules guys.
I know in situations like this it's awkward to say, but yeah.
I'm trying to figure out a puzzle.
Can I bring it in here and smash this building instead?
Oh wait!
Oh no,
I'm getting too small.
I'm getting too small!
I'm too slow!
Diagnostic warning.
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented.
Guys, I think I'm starting to literally lose brain cells.
I can't figure out any of these puzzles anymore.
I'm so tired!
Oh my gosh, you can see it right there.
Look at that.
Where does that go to?
Guys, I think I messed up.
Guys, I think I messed up!
We're free!
Wait a second, I need to go this way.
Wait, how do I...yeah, I need to get bigger.
No!
I'm so close to what you need to do.
I am.
Diagnostic warning.
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented.
Yeah we get it.
GLADOS.
Oh my gosh.
Is there something I need to get inside?
Maybe here?
Is this supposed to happen?
Is...
What?
No?
Oh it's a glitch.
OK.
You can't tell with these types of games.
You can't tell.
Maybe I need to read this.
A reminder called Jungle's Management.
Music too dang loud.
Scent of burned curry.
Yummy curry.
Shipments of food coming here.
Don't have space for more.
Ask if they can hand out flyers for testing.
Also ask RySan Medical for increased canister order frequency.
Paradox behavior 101.
AKA don't do it never.
Hmm...
Diagnostic warning.
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented.
Never...
I think I figured it out!
Oh!
Oopsie!
Why do I have to be so stinking small though?
I did it!
I just grabbed it and took it in.
Yeah!
What are you?
Not an exit.
I don't think we are going to find an exit anymore because you are small.
Here we go.
Windows.
Exclamation point.
Oh!
This liminal is super.
Like it was just made.
Wow!
Everything is black and white.
Doctor!
Deception?
Instead of reception it's deception?
Man, even the vending machines in this world suck.
Deception...
Disgrace...
They lie into us.
This is like super liminal.
Wait a minute!
Oh my gosh!
Holy loud!
Oracle of Nintendo Direct, what are they going to announce next?
I don't know.
There is too much pressure.
Erase me.
Relaxia.
Minerals.
Female toads.
You had me at female.
Guys, are we ever going to see the light of day again?
Not an exit.
Everything is so gloomy inside now.
Is this a door?
Oh yes it is.
There we go.
What is your wisdom?
No Nihongo before 8 AM.
I'm almost there.
I'm going to touch it.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's so high up.
No, it's too high up for me.
No it's not.
This is my world.
But in white space, I also faced the greatest challenge I could imagine.
Because with a lifetime of life itself behind me, and all of the weight that it carried, I realized that seeing things the way I wanted to was not as easy as it used to be.
Mister, I'm confused.
What's going on?
I'm so confused.
Majin D, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
You should be.
Wait, hold on before we do something that seems so final as turning off the lights.
I would like to take a look around at our statue.
Oh wait.
I can get on.
Nice.
I can get up.
I can climb everything.
There is no mountain that I can't climb.
Climb.
Ain't no mountain high enough.
Oh, there we go.
Find the game save.
This is a...
Wow.
That's... You see this?
See how that disappears?
That's like looking at a VTuber sideways.
If you were to look at me sideways, that's exactly how I would be.
Do we take the red and the blue door?
Or do we take the red and the yellow door?
So skinny.
Yeah, sorry.
Why not both?
OK, we'll go through this.
One.
OK, what do we do?
What do we do here?
Were you super smart and figured everything out on your own and didn't use chat's help because you were a super big brain ghost?
Yeah.
I was pretty smart.
Right guys?
I did a lot of things on my own with little hints.
Yes.
Yeah.
Genius.
OK, this part though, I'm confused.
Show us your genius.
That's like so sensitive.
Wait, which way did I come from?
Wait, if I try going backwards, does it do anything?
I'm going the opposite direction now.
I think.
Ah.
Does the red have...
Stare into the void?
I don't see green.
Remember the gimmick of the stage?
Wait, what was the stage?
I don't remember the stage at all actually.
What was the stage?
Black and white?
I'm actually so confused.
Guys?
Hold on.
Abandon your concepts.
You were really close.
Wait, I was?
I don't know at what point I was close, but...
I believe you.
My brain hurts.
The box.
This one.
I'm here.
Stop thinking logic.
Become color!
I become color!
I'm so angry.
After all, if this is a place of pure perspective, isn't it also a place where a different point of view could make anything possible?
Isn't that why you came here?
I don't know why I'm here.
Why are there dumpsters in this pristine city?
Why are there dumpsters here?
There are so many doors.
Oh my gosh, look at all the water coolers.
Checkmate.
And my queen.
Very small.
Wait a second, that door is not going to get any closer.
Where is it?
Oh my gosh.
That was just... Wait, where did that go?
It landed on my head.
Wait a second.
Wait, so I can't go in the white or the black?
I think if I put something there...
It becomes solid.
Oopsie.
Is that good enough?
Yeah.
I almost did it again.
Checkmate.
Do I need it here too?
Just in case.
Nice.
She's going to sacrifice herself.
We can go through this door.
It's not a door.
Or we can go through the other door.
Wait, how would I even get up there?
Wait.
Wait, I made it.
Wait, how did I... I think it shrunk, no?
Or is it just...
No.
Forget about the doors.
Yeah, screw the doors.
Screw the doors.
I have to go through that door.
This is a closed box everybody.
It's an actual box this time.
Don't limit yourself they said.
Think outside the box they said.
Why would you put me in this box?
Are you sure?
Sure.
Be the box.
I am the box.
Sorry, my eyes are starting to hurt me.
Wait.
I was going to grab it, but I don't think I can.
Can I grab this door?
One second.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I got a...
Sorry, I got a text and it scared me.
So I was scared, but I'm okay.
Okay, nevermind.
Words.
Yeah, everything is okay though.
Anyway, what was I doing?
Please come here.
What if I ask...
Really nicely.
I say, please.
Please go inside!
Shove it in there.
Stick it in.
It's too big.
It opened.
It opened though.
Oh, dang it.
It closed.
I don't think it was ever really open.
What?
Why is it become...
Can you put it in the other door?
I think I tried and it didn't work.
Oh.
Are you kidding me?
I thought I tried!
It's always the back to cheese.
I still need to make it bigger though.
I'm bigger!
Bigger!
White background is tricky.
It hurts my eyes so much.
Let's try the cheese.
Giant cheese.
Holy cow!
I don't know why I can get the cheese so big.
But nothing else.
Come on cheese.
Giant cheese.
OK.
There we go.
Mickey!
That's me!
Thanks for the super chat.
This is bad apple.
Oh wow.
No?
OK.
This is the motion sickness thing.
I think I'm mostly OK.
Do I just keep going?
I thought it was a special trick.
I see what you mean!
There we go.
Into the void.
It doesn't have it in there.
Exit!
There is the alarm!
What does it say?
7.59 AM!
Wait, did YouTube break as I...
Did YouTube break when I jumped in?
That's so funny.
8 AM.
Oh my god, still?
They should hire me.
For real.
This place.
What's that sound?
So you just made all this up so I would feel special?
You made all this up so I would feel like I was a special, unique individual?
No!
He's just trying to avoid a loss.
Hello!
I want to play B-Ball.
He's just gaslighting.
For real!
I was here.
Send me to the next place.
It's marked off!
No!
We
are going through all the places we went through!
I didn't think I would beat this today, I'll be honest.
I did!
And then also my chat helped me.
They were like, let's forget about that part.
That part was spooky.
We did it!
I was saying spooky and freaky and then I accidentally said spreeky.
Great stream man.
Thank you kitty!
I miss my kitty.
The dice!
Dream soda!
Spreeky!
Wake up!
Yippee!
We did it!
Can't wake up Wake me up!
Wake up!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
Yay!
Congratulations on finishing the game!
I can't believe it!
We did it!
One goal!
Thank you so much for the pink!
Good morning Mito!
This is everything that happens in your head when I'm possessing you.
Manifold garden.
What's that?
The first time I beat it I teared up at the ending.
I don't know what it is about these types of games that just make you so...
I don't know.
They make you really think.
Not just because it's a puzzle game but also just like...
It's so Emo-y at the ending.
They always make it such an adventure.
They went to an institute to cure their crippling insomnia.
Wakes up, snooze alarm, goes back to sleep.
The glasses worked?
My glasses.
I told you I was smart.
I told you.
Sometimes some puzzles really get me though and some I can figure out so quickly.
Smart.
Salvi!
Thank you so much for the red!
Red!
I just finished the game.
Thank you.
You look good with glasses too.
Smart Minky, give me your wisdom.
Roll again.
Thanks for dreaming.
Oh wait.
Hold on.
I'm waiting.
My Goshi.
Thank you star.
If I click out of the game, you'll see it does like the...
Turbo lover, thank you for the 5 gifted.
Rayback, thank you for that gifted.
Thank you!
It stops the music so I didn't wanna...Oh there we go.
IWSFJ, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm gonna get the soundtrack for this game 100%.
They have it on Steam.
I got this game, I have Game Pass.
So it was free on Game Pass.
But the soundtrack I will 100% buy.
The view finder is bendy.
Catching a minstream in itself is like a dream.
Can't open or welcome to membership.
Just wanted to say I appreciate you a lot Minto.
My Goshi.
I don't feel like I have so much I could say.
Hasn't already been said before maybe.
And probably better by other people.
If you need a chuckle.
If you need a chuckle, I'm here.
This is fun though.
I really enjoyed this game.
I like puzzle games.
And this one, I felt, had just enough challenge and also...
Not making me want to tear my hair out.
So it's good.
Try Princess, thank you!
Is it so well?
Thank you!
Interesting game, indeed.
Makes me want to try.
I probably won't be doing the extra modes, but...
I had a dream I was Haley Steinfeld.
Who's that?
And fishing.
I wish I was fishing.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Chancellor!
Praise the sun!
So excited.
Welcome back!
Thanks for a whole month.
Did you already play the Stanley Parable?
Did I stream the Stanley Parable?
I feel like I did.
I'm gonna check.
I know I've played it though.
Bears!
Thanks for the 20th, dude!
Limbo.
I've never played Limbo.
I did, right?
Surely at some point.
Stanley Parable.
This is how I look up stuff on YouTube.
I wrote Stanley Parable.
Yeah, see I did!
I did, I did.
9 months ago!
Almost a year.
For you!
I developed a certain sentimentality towards this game because it's one of the first I ever watched an ENVY Tuber be on stream.
Actually, it's funny you mention that because when I saw this game, I was like, oh, I never played this game and I want to try it.
And also, even seeing it myself, I felt so nostalgic, right?
And so I was just like, I wonder if other people will also feel kind of like, ah, this reminds me of those good old days.
I mean, now can still be good old days.
Whatever days you enjoy are the good old days.
So, it's a new game by Stanley Parable devs.
Really?
Oh, look at that, thank you.
I didn't know.
Doki, thanks for the pop gift.
So...
Any day with Finto is the best day.
I appreciate it.
You don't have to hold me in such high regard.
But I appreciate it.
If you have fun, you know.
Why am I crafting tables?
Because!
Phantom Knight, thank you so much for the pop gift.
So I say that you're the best mint that ever minted.
Thank you, Solstice.
Thank you.
For the next Nintendo Direct, can you predict the Fire Emblem Awakening remake?
I don't know.
People say that I have the gift of prophecy now, but I've been begging for it.
I've been literally saying Tomodachi Life 2 for like 2 years.
For more than 2 years.
For many years.
I've been like, Tomodachi Life 2 is today.
Tomodachi Life 2.
That's actually why I started doing the Direct Watch Alongs.
Because I was like, I want the Tomodachi Life 2 eventually.
Eventually we'll get it.
What if we had never gotten it?
I guess I would have had to stick around forever.
Doing Nintendo Directs.
Maybe.
Love you, Mint.
Thank you, Optive.
Thanks for 6 months.
React channel.
The chat summary said you're nostalgic.
Am I?
That's so sweet.
Warm up your little heart.
Okay, this music is making me so sleepy.
I will.
I will go to sleep now.
I have a busy day tomorrow too.
I have to push back Devil May Cry a couple hours.
So I'll make the waiting room tonight.
And I will post about it.
Because I accidentally scheduled some recording on top of Devil May Cry.
I'm sorry.
So basically I was texting my hair salon.
My tax person.
And my recording person.
All at the same time.
On Tuesday.
And I thought I was texting my tax person.
But I was actually texting my recording person.
My tax person is not going to take nearly as long as it's going to be for recording.
And so I was just like, oh yeah, I can do this time.
And then I was like, oh no, I can't do this time.
Oh no.
And then I accidentally scheduled them on top of each other too.
Such a mess.
Sorry, I just pinched myself.
Oh yeah.
So...
I was like...
I was so overwhelmed.
And I was all over the place.
I've been kind of all over the place with stuff this week.
Because I have a lot of things I need to get done by the end of this month.
Thank you so much for the five gift card.
That was another reason to remind us to thank Minki for being there.
What do you mean?
You had three streams today.
I know.
And then I got another thing added today that I need to finish.
Oh gosh, I have so many deadlines.
Juggling appointments, like that gesture that's popular on Twitter nowadays.
Bilateral?
John?
Filed a voice recording of my taxes with the salon.
But I got my hair appointment.
And I got my recording tomorrow.
And I got my tax thing.
So...
I got to schedule another recording.
Exciting things, you guys.
Cool things are happening.
But you won't see them for like several many months.
So, sorry.
Right now is busy time and then it will pay off later.
I hope.
What's that sound?
I hope you guys had fun.
And listened to some good soothing music tonight.
And, you know, just kind of take it easy.
You have to get off Twitter.
Get off Twitter.
If you have to get off, you know...
If you have to...
Wait, I should finish that sentence.
If you have to get off the internet.
There you go.
I'm not judging what you do.
In your free time.
We are in no judgment zone.
Mostly.
Anyway, I'm gonna go before I make this anymore.
Anymore dangerous.
Anymore yabai.
Otsumito everybody.
Thank you so much for the stream today.
Thank you for the help also.
You guys were great help for...
Helping me with...
With the puzzles without really giving things away sometimes.
Until I was like really like...
I don't know what to do.
But then even then like that one puzzle you helped us...
I still didn't understand it until you guys described it.
The one with the exit sign.
So I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Otsumito.
See you guys later.
And I'll see you when I see you next.
Itterassha.
Have a good night.
Bye, bye.
Bye, bye, bye, bye.